il est avec nous un des quatre
astronautes canadiens certifié david
saint-jacques bonsoir est-ce qu'on tire
à la courte paille comme en salle est-ce
qu'il regagne des entrevues comment ça
marche tout savoir
parce que vous voulez y aller voulait
être celui qui sera choisi j'imagine que
ça depuis qu'on est tout petit
évidemment est d'inspiration pour
d'autres je pense pour des unelles
générations entières de terriens c'est
vraiment un rêve planétaire comment
c'est fait les sélections seront en
général pour l'émission un côté s'est
dit content de prof est le choix parfait
le choix moi même ses décisions souvent
très difficile plein de facteurs qui
rentrent en ligne de compte dont la
compatibilité de l'équipage au complet
on essaie toujours en général de faire
le choix le plus tard possible tout en
permettant les sens quand même septembre
pour l'entraînement d'avoir lieu là pour
minimiser les chances d une maladie ou
une chose comme ça donc effectivement on
est quatre astronautes canadiens en ce
moment actif tout cela tous sont tous
éligibles ps qu'il faut réaliser ses
terres on pourrait penser que comme une
compétition entre nous mais la réalité
c'est que ce qu'on exige de l'astronaute
pour être est une mission spatiale
c'est tellement élevés qu'ils n'étaient
pas pas dépasser tout seul mot quand je
suis arrêté en l'espace de deux ans sur
la station spatiale
j'ai besoin de l'aide de mes collègues
de leur support et j'en ai bénéficié
énormément et n'importe lequel de nous
sera choisi de les trois autres vont
travailler fort en arrière scène pour
pour aider celui qui est sur la scène de
nous ce qui est sur la scène pour ses
missions qui ont vraiment est très
inspirante
c'est très beau et c'est sincère je suis
sur ce travail du lit puis il y en aura
un qui va y aller les autres devront se
pratiquer pourquoi la lune david saint
jacques
pourquoi on va lui tourner autour de la
lune mais alors de deux raisons peu
distingue d'abord on a encore des choses
à apprendre sur la lune en soit là il ya
beaucoup de choses pour eux en italie
des années 70 mais toujours des petits
voyages très court d'une semaine maximum
jean de jour là on veut s'installer pour
de bon avec les bases get sa son ghetto
et dans l'environnement lunaire on veut
y aller de manière plus prolongée qui
voit
plus ancré dans le temps pour faire une
bonne colonisation mais pour que ça
devienne grande partie de notre
s'installer longtemps mais on tournerait
on tourne on va tourner autour de la
lune longtemps mais vote ont installé
des bâtiments sur la lune c'est pas
prévu en ce moment mais c'est concevable
est né ce qu'il faut réaliser si c'est
que tout ça et qu'on est entrevu dans la
perspective de jours aller sur mars on
s'est un peu comme une pratique pour
marc c'est beaucoup et c'est comme si
depuis vingt ans dans un opéra en
apprenant à vivre dans l'espace à bord
de la station internationale
on a fait du camping dans notre cour
pour si on veut améliorer votre
équipement la lune c'est comme aller sur
une montagne à une autre voiture de chez
nous on peut revenir ça va mal mais
c'est beaucoup plus loin et marché comme
l'everest
là il faut vraiment être très avant
d'aller là donc il ya des choses qu'on
va énormément ce qu'on va prendre en
vivant sur la lune autour de la lune
plus à plus long terme qui vont pour
cela nous rend plus confiants on est
capable de se rendre sur mars ce jour
qui ferait vraiment pour des générations
futures en les premiers êtres humains
aller sur mars c'est pas moi ou mes
collègues c'est des gens qui sont des
enfants en ce moment bon ben justement
j'avais montré le graphique parce que la
lune c'est quoi ça mais trois jours vous
mettriez trois jours à y aller on voit
que freud et six mois pour aller sur
mars et c'est à peu près ça ouais alors
pour s'affaler sur un chiffre au rôle à
la lune c'est à peu près 1000 fois plus
loin que la station spatiale qui mars et
encore pas très mille fois plus loin que
les nounous est un autre c'est là qu'en
connaissant mars et qu'on garde la terre
ça ressemble à ce que ce dont marc
salaire vu de la terre le ciel mais
quand on dit que ceux qui liront les
premiers vers mars
ça sera bien simple ils ne reviendront
pas contenu du teint est ce que c'est
encore ça où ce n'est plus non oui vous
faites référence à des ententes a du
sens dans les médias il ya quelques
années il a eu cette idée là qui étaient
sortis de les femmes colonisation en
mars avec des billets aller simple c'est
parce qu'on poursuit en ce moment ces
procès du tout
non non ce sont des phrases le crêpier
de retour et puis mais on n'est pas prêt
à les leur du tout on eu tellement à
apprendre dans la soirée spéciale autour
de la terre le cul on l'habite depuis de
manière permanente depuis vingt ans mais
à chaque mois il ya une pièce majeure
d'équipements qui brise qui ont tant
aurait des pistes de recharge mars soit
possible alors on va apprendre tout ça
en allant sur la lune et c'est important
pour le canada c'est qu'on contribue une
jeune et nouvelle génération de
robotique pour le faux la station ghetto
et est doté d une artificielle pour être
plus autonome et tout ça s'agite
investissements massifs qui vont générer
plein d'emplois dues sur plein de tout
un nouveau pan de l'économie
et comme comme astronaute comptable mais
comme canada.com père de famille comme
citoyen je suis comme si comme c'est un
genre de pays que je veux donner à mes
enfants un pays innovant qui a poussé
les limites de la science médicale sur
technologique etc c'est vraiment une
belle nouvelle pour tout le monde avec
saint jacques merci nous avons parlé en
direct on va reparler de ça évidemment
merci et à très bientôt
merci